[Music]
there is nothing that makes me happier
than
biting into a fresh piece of bread this
slice
is absolutely fabulous in 1932
my grandfather pierre puellan started
his very
first bakery for over 88 years my
grandfather my father and i
have nurtured half a dozen shops between
paris and london
baking between three and five thousand
loaves a day
when i was 16 my mother suggested that i
start my apprenticeship
while i was finishing up my
apprenticeship my parents passed away in
a helicopter accident
the next day instead of going down to
the bakehouse
i went up to my father's desk and here i
was
in charge of puella
[Music]
in this class i will be teaching you
breads that we do at the bakery
but the most important lesson i will
teach you is how to attune your five
senses
when you're baking bread you have four
ingredients water
flour salt and a rising agent
you're going to learn how to bake breads
using sourdough wheat
rye learning how to start your very own
starter
we will be baking breads of yeast
fandumi
cornbread brioche and also what to do
with breads
from its freshest to its stales don't be
afraid
it's very easy do not be discouraged by
failed attempts that's what your journey
is about
baking really is an essential and
beautiful craft
[Music]
practice these recipes share them spread
the love and enjoy every single step
remember apollon is a master class
you